Mr Pusheen meow to
to the waffle Factory and had myself
some some nice waffles
um but uh
you know
um I wasn't drunk
so I take serious offense to that
I'm doing this I think this is the first
time I do this in my life but
I remember
uh back in the days
when I was young
um I used to watch lennaro's tournaments
and
um
there were all these
short draws
and
I remember like thinking because
all these top players are making short
draws then that's probably pretty
it's a cool thing to do so like even I
was offering short draws as well so this
is a case of me
um seeing
people like ikaru people like Wesley
making this
four star in the Berlin a lot of times
and
I want to be cool like them you know I
want to do it for once
for once I want to
um
I want to make this Berlin repetition as
well
to be like the others
and I promise as white I'll never ever
do it again this is the one time
usually when I want to draw I play some
rookie one berlins instead
of this
foreign